welcome back and uh you know given these
uh really exciting sessions I think we
have we are set up for a great panel
discussion
that's why I dance who is um he's the
director of uh ciqc I want our Quantum
Center on campus
which it also for school system
Simon's
so I'll let you introduce the
oh boy okay I'm going to actually ask
the panelists mostly to introduce
themselves because they've been mostly
on the stage so hopefully that'll be
okay with you but um actually I'd like
to start off the panel because we have
two members uh of the panel who were not
among the speakers so maybe what I'll do
first is just direct a question to them
and then they can uh introduce
themselves by way of response so let me
I'll start with uh with you uh Jonathan
uh you're the uh Chief scientist and
co-founder at atom Computing great to
have you here so here's my question for
you so I'm uh an atomic physics
experimentalist and uh in my lab my grad
students when they're not on strike they
do
um they do experiments they actually
trap single atoms and and measure their
properties so
um if I if I or my students walked into
your Labs at Adam Computing what would
they find that's the same or what would
they find that's very different
okay yeah I mean what's the same is a
lot of the techniques you know a lot of
Thor Labs lab snacks boxes probably
would be would be the same
um so I think a lot of the individual
components and the techniques would look
similar they'd be in a familiar
environment and I think what would look
different though is that um I would say
in industry and when you're kind of
building up the systems that we build
uh more and more of your time kind of
changes over time from being in the lab
building playing with or Labs components
and you eventually always end up doing a
lot of software engineering to actually
build the infrastructure that runs your
experiment calibrates your experiment
and integrates it with the larger
software stack in the company so I'd say
the the focus on having at least some
base level of software engineering
skills is uh is probably a difference or
a greater maybe a greater focus on
software engineering skills I'd say
so others who have made the crossover
into uh experiment experimental work in
uh industry is that a similar feeling
yeah I I agree with that uh I think that
there's actually a lot of
going from Academia to Industry one of
the things that uh I've come to realize
is that we are now in charge of building
all of the infrastructure which is
something that comes for free almost
when you're in Academia so software is
is a big component about to it but the
other thing is
while we do a lot of kind of proof of
concept uh builds for next generation
tools the the design process that goes
into building new machines is very
different than at least what I saw when
I was in in Academia uh there's there's
really much more of an engineering drive
to make things more reliable to make
them easier to reproduce to maintain and
so on so there's there's a lot of work
that goes into
modularizing things and and uh
standardizing them that I think is
absent in Academia
okay well I'm gonna switch to something
very different so it's good to have chin
Mai here chin Mai was a PhD here at
Berkeley right and now you're at uh IBM
that's right and one of the things that
one of your uh Foci during your graduate
work was uh working on this no trivial
low energy states theorem right which
was an important outstanding theorem
that okay now I'm gonna butcher it uh
that says that there's a class of
hamiltonians for which all the low
energy state eigenstates are guaranteed
not to be simple
in the sense that there would have been
uh producible by a finite gate set from
some product state to begin with did I
get it right that's right all right
great so that's kind of a physics
statement
um I understand that from a physics
point of view but there's also a sense
in which this is like a big deal for
Quantum Computing so can you kind of
explain that connection and how how far
uh in inference we should draw
um yeah so this notion that
are there interesting Quantum systems
which we might want to understand which
classically don't have good descriptions
that's one way to sort of put it in the
sense that if you were to try to
describe it it takes a really big
circuit now
what does that mean exactly in terms of
physics well
you could think of it in many ways you
could think of it as hey if you were
able to actually construct the state and
you're able to certify that you created
this kind of interesting topological
phase of matter then you've you have a
provable
complexity argument to back up that it's
novel
fundamentally different topological
phase manner
um another thing is more broadly is I
think there's this nice touch in
Academia where you try to understand
impossibility results it's a much bigger
interest in that whereas in Industry
there's a lot more of like what can you
do despite noise despite all these
things so that's where these two things
get along
mm-hmm
but does it does it tell us so what does
it tell us also about
um
you know so I I think that one of the
connections of course being between
physics hamiltonian models and uh
Quantum Computing is through this idea
of adiabatic Quantum Computing right so
if I have a model which in its ground
state heck actually in a lot of it's
excited States also has the answer to
some interesting numerics problem then
there's a possibility of
um by uh adiabatic uh evolution of
getting into that state so
um
is this ntls telling us that that's
uh first of all legitimate but secondly
is it is it easier than we thought it
was
that sort of adiabatic approach to
quantum computer
uh I don't think it actually says much
about adiabatic Computing it's
unfortunately a little bit crude in that
it just says the circuit model it takes
a lot of circuit depth and the reality
is to convert from the adiabatic model
to the Circuit model that you know
there's some blow ups there so it's not
exactly clear what it says about the
hardness in the adiabatic model but
that's by itself another interesting
question you could ask is can I write
down hamiltonians for which adiabatic
evolution is not a good candidate for um
solving these things it would take a
long time for an adiabatic improvably
that would be like a adiabatic nlts
statement you could ask that and that's
really worth thinking about also so
okay all right well thanks
um is all be applied to the d-wave
system
um I'm not sure okay
so maybe I'll switch questions so now
you guys kind of introduced anyhow so
you've met you've moved now into uh uh
working at IBM and like what's what's
the work you're doing there oh I am um
I'm a complexity theorist actually I
don't think they let me even into the
rooms with the devices it's complicated
enough they don't need you in there it's
probably for the best I think the worst
thing I would do is probably step on
something and break a million dollars
piece of equipment okay good very wise
all right
so with that in mind maybe we can sort
of explore a little bit the quantum
industry landscape
so there's uh now a pretty wide sector
of the economy that seems to be
interested in and committing resources
to Quantum Computing by various uh
Investments so what what do you guys see
as the main driver for this
um broadened interest
not an easy question
um what's the main driver where I think
uh you guys have been driver is first we
it starts with good theoretical results
in Quantum Computing right
um basically
I would say results in complexity Theory
actually right that we understand
uh a fair amount of things about
complexity Theory uh there is these
thesis that tourists during thesis that
says that
um
different computational models are
equivalent there is a strong version of
that that says that different
computational models are
um
equivalent as well in terms of
efficiency
and then Along Comes Quantum computation
and the I guess the hypothesis is that
there are certain
computational tasks that can be solved
exponentially faster with quantum
computers than classical algorithms so I
think that's a very big paradigm shift
in computation right so that really
sounds interesting
um so
uh then okay so that you have these nice
interesting theoretical results there is
of course Source algorithm that of
course grab a lot of people attention
meaning when the computers in principle
could break
what is the standard method today of
public uh cryptography so that's will be
you know very interesting for some
agencies I guess not necessarily for
industry
um
and then on the other side you well you
can say well these are all nice
theoretical results but maybe this is
all a pipe dream this is always going to
be magical qubits as you were saying and
it turns out that there has been you
know since these results which is
already almost 20 years ago I guess
right or more actually getting to 30
then there was like a phase of wow this
is very interesting but it's very hard
but then I think in the last decade
Maybe
there has been a lot of progress on the
error rates of experimental processors
the way John and others were describing
it so it I think it just I mean it
remains super hard to build a quantum
computer but is starting to look
approachable this is starting to look
you know hard but believable so I agree
with your monkey said like if we don't
improve or keep it maybe in five years
we won't be saying the same things but
you know as you said like we think we
can improve our kids right so
uh so then we have a I think a strong
theoretical foundation for why this is
uh interesting Endeavor from the point
of view of computation and then we have
enough experimental progress so that it
starts to look believable so I think
that's uh why you know at least big
companies that work on computation like
you know work at Google so Google user
but Google does is computation right so
enough to at least make you know some
modest investment it's not like it's the
biggest investment at Google but you
know for this as Google is certainly you
know it's a modest but but important
investment I think on the what is the
future of computing right and then I
there are other Industries as well that
are not just computation but
um I guess there is always a little bit
of fear of being left behind but that
you know so I think it's probably
appropriate if you're not building your
own on the computer or having your own
according within group you want to have
some
um
knowledge of how the field is evolving
so that
it doesn't happen to you like I don't
know with electric cars for instance
that then you know electric cars is the
thing of the future until it's not and
then there is some other company that is
dominating that market right so
uh this is still very early days I don't
think
they're you know it's gonna be it is not
a profitable
investment right now in terms of
um commercial returns uh it can be you
know profitable in other ways but it's
certainly not generating profit it's not
solving practical problems today but
depending on your industry you know 10
years which is what I think we're more
or less estimating that if everything
goes well we'll take the build up on the
computer 10 years might not be settle on
time if you are you know Goldman Sachs
has been around for 150 years right so
they probably you know if you say 10
years he's like well that's not so much
I don't know so maybe some companies
want to make sure that they at least are
not going to be surprised and that's
doesn't require a huge amount of effort
and then other companies which are more
computational they you know they really
are starting to see the Promise
of of quantum Computing so um as long as
it has a strong theoretical foundation
and we keep making Province
experimentally then I think we're gonna
you know keep those seeing those
Investments moving forward
and you grab the mic because you wanted
to China
um yeah let me try to give it to some of
those different type of answer which is
uh look I think in the last couple of
years have been a year of serious
turmoil worldwide uh in a lot of ways
that have upended a bunch of assumptions
and it reminded us that you know there
are some serious ex potentially
existential crises that we have to deal
with I mean right now probably top of
mind is nuclear war okay which we sort
of forgot was a possibility but you know
it's real and another one is is climate
change is potentially an existential
threat and you know if we're going to
tackle that uh you know we have to think
about things like carbon capture from
the atmosphere uh better ways to do
nitrogen fixation and if you really
think about that entails it means we are
going to have to do the last 100 years
of chemistry and materials upon which
you know our society is based we have to
do in the next 20 years
okay and uh that's unlikely to be
something we're going to do by trial and
error you know
um Behavior process for nitrogen
fixation which is how all fertilizers
produced is however 100 years old it
hasn't been improved on and took a very
long time to develop for us to be able
to develop things like that for you know
essentially to head off what's
potentially an existential crisis I
think
a quantum computer could be a major tool
in our Arsenal to do that uh classical
simulations currently that we can do are
not really predictive value for those
kinds of problems and uh for chemical
reactions of large molecules involving
transition metals so uh you know the way
I look at it and that you know which is
I think is reflected in Microsoft's
perspective is there are some really big
problems that we need to solve that
Humanity needs to solve in quantum
computers is is you know potentially a
way to to solve them to be to be
interested in these things
um yeah I just want to build on so so I
agree with what Jaden said I think maybe
the constants might not work out in
Quantum computing's favor with things
like climate change
um
uh I mean hopefully we get those good
qubits uh sooner rather than later
but building on what Sergio said I think
he mentioned complexity Theory as a
strong theoretical foundation and I
would add to that error correction
and fall tolerance because there are a
lot of computing paradigms that have
been offered I mean analog Computing or
people talked about like DNA Computing
or things like this I don't know
um
the fact that errors can be discretized
and corrected in Quantum systems is
absolutely fundamental and is completely
different from
[Music]
any other approach that you might take
to Computing it means that quantum
computers are in principle scalable as
long as we can get our errors to be
error rates themselves to be low enough
and close enough to Independent
um we have no evidence at all that there
are fundamental obstacles to building
large-scale quantum computers
um so it's not it's not just that we
have these I mean there's great
complexity results for analog computers
but we don't think we'll ever be able to
build one because there's no
um there's no compelling reason to
believe that we can you know store real
numbers and compete with them to
arbitrary Precision so um this fact
really cements the quantum computer as a
fundamentally new and stable Paradigm in
in computation and without that we
wouldn't we wouldn't be sitting here
I I agree with that but I I do want to
say that
the it's very hard to answer this
because we're treating you know money
going into Quantum Computing as being
like a single source and it's really
many different sources and I think that
the motivation for
them can be very different
some of them from
I think that in some measure all of them
are a combination of
hope and fear
the hope that Quantum Computing will
deliver on the promise that has been you
know
been presented since uh almost 40 years
ago now
uh and there's you know there's there's
many
there's many
hand wavy arguments about why quantum
computer I mean there's there's a very
solid foundation of complexity Theory
but there's also hand wavy arguments
about why Quantum Computing will be
better at solving particular types of
problems
and I think that people want to believe
that
but that's not enough I think that it
has to come also with
some level of fear because if it's just
hope then it's fine for it to keep
moving in the background but there has
been
a growing feeling that
while Quantum Computing has always felt
like it's 10 20 years in the future
recently it's felt much more real
because of the the fast progress in
Hardware demonstrations
and that has led people to
to look at what happens if quantum
Computing is real and we're not the
first ones to get it right
uh and this goes from governments to uh
commercial players that
get to be on the Leading Edge either by
having very small advantages that
compound greatly where those that have
such a long
time Horizon for the kinds of things
that they do that investing in something
now that may not pay off in you know
five or ten years is still worth doing
because the things that they're doing
now may still be affected by that
okay so somebody in this room is going
to write the book Quantum Computing hope
and fear okay just so you know
okay
um so related to that so you know we all
want to move the
the quantum computer into into being
we're all part of this endeavor and you
can sort of adopt different strategies
toward getting there you can sort of go
for the you know the really long shot uh
try something
um declare that you're going after some
goal that is you know pretty out there
uh pretty ambitious of course if you
succeed then everybody's very far ahead
or you can
um take a more I guess gradualist
approach you can chip away at your error
budgets you can
um you know try to refine and really
grow slowly from from the bottom up
um
you know I I see representations of both
those approaches I see both of them both
within industry efforts and also within
academic Labs like both of those uh
styles of making progress are at play so
what do you think what does it take
what's what's the right approach to move
this forward
some of you have declared yourself to be
of one type or the other uh in those uh
yeah I mean strategies
maybe there's maybe a couple answers to
it I think my personal opinion is
somewhat balanced on it I mean we need
some of both I I don't think it's one
approach or the other but I guess
speaking from experience uh from the
experience of somebody who's at you know
Venture Capital funded startup which
might be different than the experiences
of other people in this room
some of the gradual approach is almost
uh necessary because that's how you get
funding you need to get Milestones you
need to show by you know the next time
you need to raise venture capital from
investors that you've made progress and
I think a few players in the field have
tried to make more of the pitch that
they're just gonna shoot for the moon
right away but I think it's much easier
to much easier to have the conversation
with investors that you're uh you know
you can measure progress even quarterly
or certainly every year and so I think
from the standpoint of venture capital
funded startup I think it's just a
necessity to do that and then the
challenge we have is to balance that
also with the understanding that you
know there's a long-term Vision which is
Fault tolerant error correction quantum
computers the solution to that's not
going to be there by the next board
meeting and so we need to make sure
we're also developing kind of our
long-term technology roadmap and
maybe veering into another topic I think
that's actually where collaborations
with Academia for smaller companies like
ours can actually be very helpful to
kind of you know work on the longer time
Horizon projects sort of the academic
collaboration context while still
pushing forwards our roadmap internally
in the company
foreign
so if anyone has read Peter thiel's book
zero to one describing startups that's a
really good book that at one point in a
later chapter and he describes the um
kind of the attitude of an indefinite
Optimist or a definite optimist
so the indefinite Optimist says look we
have all these different approaches
we're funding them all uh we'll see
which one works and that's actually the
that's how r d basically works
uh and uh and that's a good model right
and that's basically what you do at the
University however uh he only doesn't
say that directly uh Peter teal also
says that the definite positive where
you have a definite goal a definite way
of doing things your milestones for the
next quarter or year
um uh is definitely how startups work
uh and uh you know definitely that's
more industrial but I would say still
there's a big tendency to be indefinite
uh because that way you never have to
worry about your company failing or your
project failing that's the last thing we
all want so we try to be kind of in
indefinite as we can oh sure as we can
get away with okay so um for example
with the quantum Supremacy experiment I
was really excited that that was a
definite experiment
amen we could fail and then if we failed
no one wanted to fail that's why it's
kind of crazy to do it but I figured if
we'd fail we're going to learn something
and then we're going to know what to fix
so uh I I say you know it's risky to do
definite experiments but then it forces
you to get things right which in turns
the group did
so that it's it's read T Peter thiel's
book he really describes this quite well
all right so maybe on the topic of uh
industry as it interacts with Academia
so here's a challenge or here's a
question like what's a um
well what's a result that's come out of
Academia recently that you think is a
game changer for the quantum industry
of these definite optimism
and I talked about it uh particularly
for
the neutral atom platform and and this
is actually kind of tied to your
previous question where I think that
it's important that
you have a clear long-term Vision even
if you don't have
the most precise roadmap about how to
get there but
it's a little bit like navigating in a
in a foggy Street you know where you're
going and you can see a little bit ahead
of you and you stay focused on making
that progress but I think that
sometimes you just have to
be
you need to be flexible enough to take
opportunities when they come and I think
that this is I mean it's a very hard
judgment call when that happens uh but
like specifically something that came
out of of the academic Labs that has
been shaping our thinking about uh near
and Midterm uh algorithms
is this ability to
reconnect chips as part of the of the
computation and it's because
it's not just the fact that it gives
more flexibility but the fact that it
allows you to start
thinking about
a more sophisticated architecture where
you can have functional areas in the
same way that you do with things like Al
use within a classical computer
so moving away from this
static chip where you have very very
costly ways of moving Quantum
information to just move the thing
that's easy to move and preserve the
quantum information that has been
quite instrumental in how we're thinking
about the future for us
I think the uh invention of good Quantum
ldpc codes has the potential to
radically change how we build quantum
computers in I don't know five years
maybe 10 years these are codes that
still have low weight parity checks just
like the surface code they have some
degree of geometric non-locality but
unlike the service code which encodes
one qubit into n qubits these encode
order n qubits into n qubits
[Music]
um
the existence I mean we use these codes
every day in our the classical analogs
of these codes every day in our cell
phones and they're extremely powerful
we have known about these codes for
about one year only uh in the quantum
setting and we don't know a lot about
them yet we don't know great fault
tolerance protocols for them like we do
with surface codes we don't know very
many architectures that are compatible
with this idea of geometric non-locality
although uh the aquarium yeah yeah I
know I know you mentioned them briefly
in your in your talk
um
um I mean you can also Envision doing
this with like lots of crossovers on a
superconducting device or something as
well it's it's not like there's no way
to Envision doing these things but it
will take Innovation but the payoff is
there like your overheads will be so
much smaller if you can harness this and
no one's even considered thinking about
these questions because there was no
real reason to do it building surface
codes is already hard enough why why
should I pile on well now there's a real
incentive to do it because if you can do
it your overhead is going to drop you
know instead of one qubit in 100 qubits
you're gonna get 20 or something right
so I think this is a result in the last
approximately one year that does have
potential to revolutionize
um just to change gear this is about
experimental work as I've said I'm
really worried about how to make the
qubits better and I really enjoy an
experimental paper from Berkeley by
Irfan siddiki's group having to deal
with
um treating the surface of niobium and
making better qubits and what what was
great it was very academic
like and and and and they studied it
extremely well by going through the
various mechanisms TM uh xrf other
things to to do a good scientific paper
and uh you know it's not this brand new
algorithm or something but I think it
very much contributed to our knowledge
on how to make qubits better uh the
interesting thing is I'm not sure all
the conclusions are right because it's
materials and you never know it has to
be reproduced but the paper was done so
well that it it really adds a lot to the
field and that's the kind of thing that
Academia could do that's not necessarily
the kind of thing that an industrial
group would publish and uh it's very
important
foreign
keywords we had a collaboration with a
group in Germany that you know John will
know very well uh to look at the TLs of
the transmounts and I think those
results are very interesting in you know
they did some very careful experiments
trying to point out in what particular
part of the qubit you might have you
know significant percentage of TLS stls
is one of the dominant Source noise
sources of noise
and you know ideas about how to fix it
so that you know it's still early days
but it looks fairly promising if you get
you know fixed half of the tlss then you
might increase
lower Euros by faster of two that's
that's very significant and more on the
theory side computer science has which
is more what they do I like the word
that UMES and others have been doing on
uh certifiable Quantum Nest or things of
that nature I think benchmarks are super
important not just for noise but also
algorithmically and computationally and
you know to sort of make sure that
they feel disadvancing of course there
are many metrics that are important to
look at you know like you want to look
at errors per gate you want to look at
T1 in in the right context but also
algorithmically it's very important to
have good algorithmic benchmarks and
this is uh I I think that's a very
promising direction as potentially one
of the first computer science
applications of quantum computers it
sounds you know it doesn't need
necessarily like the same size as a
full-time quantum computer to do
simulations in chemistry things like
that but uh it comes with a strong
theoretical guarantee cryptographic
guarantees that this is a very hard uh
thing to reproduce classically and I
think if we manage to do that in some
intermediate line scale by you know I'm
very optimistic we will find
applications for that because we always
find applications for new computational
capabilities
and it will be you know very good for
the field in general so that's some work
that the bases are being said now in
Academia by but you know but I think
they are likely to have
important practical applications in you
know five years or something like that
we managed to escalate quantum computers
at the same time that we're reducing the
computational resources
anything else from since you're a recent
convert anything else from Academia that
they all they all should know about
um
so you know the the nice thing about
Academia is I think Academia is a little
bit less
invested in making sure that the quantum
big Quantum experiment works out right
so one is Not Afraid in Academia to
prove impossibility results and that's
something that's ready to search and
going out to go find lower bounds or
hardness and sort of draw the boundary
on the other side right
um and you know the nice thing about
when you draw the lower bounds or the
complexity is it sort of it it sort of
should set the guide rails for how
um one goes about trying to solve these
problems right it's not a
it's not saying hey don't do it or this
is totally impossible you know it sets
the guide rails
um I think the best example of this is
NP completeness you know and there's a
lot of problems which we know are NP
completeness but there are these amazing
uh
sat solvers let's solve set formulas
Crazy Fast despite the pro the fact that
it's NP complete right and they work
because they sort of look at very
specific structures it's not exactly the
complete problems and they work on a lot
of these on many instances right so
again NP completeness qma completeness
dequantization algorithms these are sort
of should be the guide rails with which
one thinks about it and then that's uh
there's a lot to be learned there right
the
uh you know some people think of
complexity results is upper bounds and
algorithms you can also think of
algorithms as uh upper bounds on the
lower bounds right so they're they're
really two sides of the same point
hey I know you probably want to get on
to the next question but I actually want
to double down on something that John
said
um you know about the importance of
materials here especially at least with
solid state qubits I mean I realize the
red bird atom case is quite different or
ions and um you know I I think in my
mind what industry is
probably better at than Academia is if
you know you have a set destination with
a somewhat deterministic path getting to
focus on going on that set path
is something that industry is relatively
good at Academia is a bit more anarchic
and freewheeling and is very good at
exploring a lot of face space you know
sort of crowdsourcing problems and
letting people explore lots of different
directions so through many people random
walking you can explore a lot of face
space but it was not the most efficient
way to get to a set destination along a
fairly you know narrow trajectory
um I think you know both of those are
things you need and when you are stuck
or backed into a corner and hard to you
know having difficulty making progress
that kind of exploration is extremely
useful because it gives you some kind of
Step function improvements that you
wouldn't get by incremental progress
um you know an example where I think
that that's been extremely fruitful and
we've seen a couple of Step function
improvements is actually in graphene so
in my mind there were two you know since
the early days when you know people
started doing first thing experiments on
graphene there were two major step
function improvements one was uh going
to these bore nitride substrates and
using born nitride as the substrate and
as your gate insulator having a high
quality crystalline insulator and that
made a huge step function Improvement in
the quality of the phenomena you saw in
graphene and the second was going to
graphite rather than metallic rather
than aluminum gates you know these are
kind of you know in probably for many
people in the audience these are in the
weeds materials things but you know they
were absolutely essential
advances which came about really through
random walk of lots of people trying
lots of different ideas that most of
which didn't work and hitting on a few
things and then the whole field
realizing their value and everybody
adopting it okay
um and you know I you know I can speak
for our program and maybe John you know
was saying some things that you know
were quite similar that you know very
basic things like having better
dielectrics
um you know you know better date
alignment you know some very you know
specific materials things are where some
of our problems are and maybe even some
of the most important problems you know
for solid state cubits and you know
Academia does have a track record of
coming up with you know ideas there so
you know I would I would you know list
that
okay so maybe I'll ask this last
question so one of the more things we
one of the other things we do in
Academia is we shovel people over your
way I was recently
um let's see asked by some Dean whatever
to fill out some form of course and um I
think I was supposed to write out what
what subjects
what domain areas what skills and what
like ways of thinking should we prepare
students
let's see I think the phrasing was so
they can go out and have lies of
significance I thought that was rather
haughty but uh
anyhow so uh I don't know if the lives
are significant so yeah I think I think
for subjects I think I said
statistics Science and History were the
three things you needed to teach
students but you guys didn't argue about
that
anyhow so all right thinking about
either domain uh knowledge or skills or
way of thinking how should we prepare
people to thrive in the quantum industry
I don't know this is what you're going
for exactly but I think that um in
addition to technical skills you know
there's a type of
you know technical management project
management how to organize yourself how
to work in a team that's not just you or
just not just you and your senior
postdoc or something that I mean and I
think I experienced this as much as
anyone I didn't really learn that in
graduate school and I think the sort of
time limited nature of your PhD and the
fact that you're supposed to kind of be
you're supposed to control your own PhD
and like become the domain expert you
know usually it doesn't lend itself to
learning how to work in a team so if you
have like 12 people with phds who are
you know combining to work on let's say
one apparatus that's that's an
unfamiliar situation I think to an Amo
physics lab or you know something else
they might get in Academia So in theory
if you have that many people who are
really skilled you should be able to
utilize them efficiently synergistically
but it's it's hard to do and um
um if I could just submit my wish list
universities is that we could somehow
include this sort of training as part of
the curriculum
probably easier said than done but that
is that is kind of the wish list
well I you know obviously there's no
answer to that question but uh I think
in general you know University
prepares people well to go to
find jobs and Industry I mean of course
also for for other things
uh
certainly in Quantum one thing that is
happening is that the set of skills that
are now required
is becoming a lot broader uh for
instance Jonathan mentioned software
before right like software is a big
problem
if as you're trying to scale you know
it's not just one-off kind of experiment
anymore
uh it becomes a way more complicated
system we if we are building a quantum
computer we cannot have to reimburse the
holes that were stuck you know like from
the control to the operating system to
the Brahmin languages so that's just
like one example but you know everything
that that
um that gets to be done in the lab one
difference for sure between
um
academian industries that yeah indeed
Academia is more free willing more you
know random walls you can go and do your
own thing and that's great because sure
through a Serendipity or for your
particular ideas you might come up with
this interesting
you know big Delta functions
industry indeed as has been said tends
to be more of our well here is the path
and we we kind of try to March together
so it's kind of a different way of
working it's more social for sure
and I I personally enjoy it like you're
not sort of working on your problem for
four days before you randomly find
somebody you know willing to listen to
you like normally you're actually
working with a bunch of people on the
same problem and everybody agrees is
important and everybody is you know
happy to to talk to each other one thing
that uh I think you have to work on
maybe you come from a strong academic
career is there is a little bit
distendency in Academia of you know
protesting your authorship or protecting
I don't know your name you know like you
want to put the paper out you don't want
to tell people results necessarily
before you actually thought them through
because they might scoop you or
something like that and in industry is
completely the opposite in Industry you
want to make sure that everybody
communicates freely maybe they can help
everybody in their problems if somebody
else solves the problem for you great
for both you know so it has to be you
cannot put you know silos if if you have
like 100 people working on on the same
project is just sure way to fail right
so it requires a little bit of adjusting
and there is still in Quantum because
it's still very academic for amount of
emphasis still on you know papers and
things like that and I think we need to
move we're moving away from that in
Industry we need to move more away from
that like it's been mentioned many times
like the most important work is not
necessarily the thing that is going to
land you the next paper you know I think
you like really we need to lower the
keyword errors right it doesn't matter
if it's going to be a nature paper but
if we don't do that we're gonna have a
bunch bigger problems so
it's important to make sure that we
create the space that people can focus
on the important problems and recognize
that even if they are not you know if
they're not going to end up in the cover
of nature
yeah so you asked what can academics do
to help students prepare for industry
jobs I think software engineering skills
of some kind is really essential just
Learn Python like have some projects
where you're forced to do a bunch of
coding in Python but it's a little more
than that you know get comfortable with
GitHub and things like this
um or or get just Version Control more
generally you get used to writing unit
tests I mean people do numerics in an
academic setting and it's like well I
did the numerix here's my notebook or
whatever and like the only person that
ever reads your code is you
um that's just not going to fly in
Industry so
um try to develop good software
development habits
um that's one thing another thing uh
industry hires interns so uh you know
there are internships available at all
the major companies at least I'm not
sure what the status is at startups uh
but you know send emails to people that
you want to work with at uh companies
um
that's a that's a major thing you know
encourage your students to do that to um
to look for internships or to cold email
people the more Junior the person the
more likely the response you know don't
cold email John Martinez he probably
gets enough or cheat on uh so
um I think those are two really big
things another one is you spend a long
time during your PhD at least uh most
people do I think there's probably
exceptional people uh for which this
doesn't apply but
they don't need my advice
um you spend a long time learning how to
fail uh repeatedly for months
right like uh this is an unnatural thing
for many people uh especially people who
go into people who are uh clever enough
and bold enough that they want to do a
PhD in physics they're not used to
failing for months at a time and it it's
uh this is something that you have to
learn how to tolerate and even enjoy and
an industry
um
you can't just simply fail repeatedly
for months
um
you you have to keep pushing and you
have to know when something is good
enough
and then you have to ship it in some
sense like this is a solution now what
is the next bottleneck now let's attack
that and that's a definitely a different
mindset not like oh I bet you I could
get another factor of two if I just
optimize this no no what's the next
bottleneck move to it now the pace is
faster
um that's been a learning experience for
me personally and something that I
wasn't accustomed to and and only upon
reflection that I realized it was
because I had spent so long
relaxing in my ability to just play
around with these factors of two and
knowing that I can fail fail fail fail
fail and it would be fine that's not
really an option in Industry so
um
uh you should learn how to fail for
months at a time during your PhD that's
an important part of doing the PHD but
then you need to um you need to get over
that as a as a modality in which you
contribute and then you need to
um keep keep your eye on the prize and
have a steady March towards progress
that's I think uh key you have to learn
how to fail fast yeah that's right make
mistakes as fast as possible John
Wheeler
I have three things that I think have
not been covered exactly as I want to
tell them the first one is events like
this I think are super important I think
that having access to
having visibility while being
at school to what people in Industry are
doing about what people in Industry are
doing how they think what they care
about
and this also comes together with
I think that in in Academia of course
there's there's an impetus to to train
academics and I think that when that is
not
thoughtfully controlled it can lead to
a perceived stigma for leaving Academia
and I think that's something that that
needs to be
very purposefully controlled that to
encourage people to go into industry and
to see the value of the work that that
that is done in industry
the second one is
second and third are related to
communication I think that in in
Academia we learn a very
specialized and sophisticated way of
writing that after many years in
Academia you come to appreciate the
beauty of but it's very hard to read an
academic paper if you're not an academic
and that
being in the in the mode of only writing
with such language makes it very hard to
communicate with others that don't have
that background so learning how to write
and how to constantly write so that
there is a track record of what you're
doing in a way that allows others to
build on top of it and it's related to
good software practices but I think this
is much more General than that and the
last one is uh similarly related to that
being comfortable there's a lot of
things in Academia that are very
uncomfortable but
something that we I don't think there's
enough exposure to is being
uncomfortable by being put
in a group of people that is very
different
and we
we create a lot of verbal shorthand
notation to communicate efficiently but
it makes it makes it very difficult to
talk with people that don't have that
shorthand notation so I think that
something that I would like to see is
more
more events more collaborations where
people are put outside of their comfort
zone to have to
not just explain what they do but
have to in real time come up with a
common link develop a Common Language
with someone else from a different
background to really be able to convey
not just what they want to say but to
make sure that the other person is
understanding because that is crucial to
working in
in in large teams that have very
different backgrounds
yeah
um so I want to just follow up on two of
the points so just doubling down on on
what Steve said and maybe taking to the
extreme is
um you know
I think in Academia we typically focus
on solving problems on finding Solutions
um you know there's another class of
activity which is to make decisions and
you know when you were trying and that's
kind of you know on this idea of like
failing repeatedly which is you'll find
a solution you you keep working until
you've found the solution if you don't
have enough information you don't have
the right solution you just keep working
but when you're trying to make a
decision by the time you have all the
information it's probably too late you
know and and you and we in Academia you
know tend to focus on solving problems
and that's what we do you solve a
problem you write a paper you know but
we actually make lots of decisions you
decide to go to grad school or not go to
grad school you decide to go to grad
school in physics or computer science to
do you know String Theory or Quantum
information you're like you make lots of
decisions but we don't actually think
very much about the decisions that you
make or even train people to make
decisions and you know in Industry you
actually have to make decisions all the
time because precisely because you're in
many cases you're trying to go along
some Seth path and you're not doing
random walk you know which which enables
you to not make a decision because
different people can explore different
things and everyone can decide their own
thing you know if you're trying as a
team to do something you have to make
some decisions so you have to get
comfortable with making decisions with
incomplete or imperfect information and
to learn how to make those kinds of
decisions and you know that's that's a
very big difference that you know we
don't particularly you know teach or
train people how to do
um uh you know a second thing is
um you know if you have a team you know
in a company working on trying to you
know especially on the hardware side you
know a team of 50 or 100 people
um
you know you don't need that 50 or 100
people to all have phds in fact it's
better if they don't to be honest with
you right you don't need 100 people with
phds in physics or petitions and physics
and computer science and math you
probably need I'm almost certain you
need some mix of people many of whom you
know don't have phds who have extensive
perhaps industry experience or master's
degree or some people who you know have
a bachelor's degree and no graduate
degrees
um
you know because in in a team of that
size there will be a fair amount of
specialization and there will be maybe
someone who's whose job is you know
just to operate the ebm lithography
system and they get very good at it and
they operate one tool or to just do a
certain type of measurement or to focus
on packaging you know there are lots of
you know the larger a team gets the you
know if you want to you know efficiently
use more budget it's going to involve
specialization and
um what's what's often difficult is
while there are lots of people with very
specialized skills and you can hire from
industry or out of out of you know fresh
out of universities they often
don't there is an impotence mismatch
between those people and the people who
have phds and are deep experts in
Quantum Computing so I think maybe you
know the thing that we probably haven't
done a good enough job is yep we have a
lot of people with deep expertise who've
gotten phds but not enough of people who
are not deep experts in Quantum
Computing you know learn enough about
other things who could be part of that
team have not learned enough of the
language of quantum Computing to to
effectively work together with people as
a team so it's it's sort of that that
that that that you know little bit of
extra knowledge that would enable people
to work you know productive because the
team is something that we're you know I
find is hard to find great
uh well in terms of learning how to make
decisions I'm going to decide that this
is the end of the panel
um so first of all let me just say what
a fabulous panel this is It's really
impressive thank you
and then if you want to say something to
wrap us up
[Music]
yeah so uh it's from my view perspective
you know it couldn't have gone better in
terms of we had the sequence of
wonderful talks and a really great panel
moderated really rather and so I feel
there's a lot to chew on at this point
the staff have been nice enough to
I I hope when we go out there should be
a tea out there so we can chew on even
more and and continue this conversation
so thank thanks everybody for
for attending
view the conversation